if you're like me when you hear the
words Alaskan divorce court you probably
is some picture in your head or like a
seven year old bounty hunter
armwrestling a one-legged prostitute
over who gets the fishing rights up a
dead guy lake it's always the bear by
the way it's always the bear but last
week in a progressive move Alaskan
courts became the first in the nation to
reclassify pets in divorce proceedings
to allow for joint custody it's a very
revolutionary are you guys thinking
about getting divorced is this very very
said you can do that very revolutionary
move in divorce proceedings because
everywhere else dogs were treated
basically the same as a car which was
causing problems in some parts of Alaska
where their dog is technically their car
[Applause]
most of us have any idea what goes on in
an Alaskan divorce court so comedians
what is an another rule you'd hear it in
an Alaskan divorce court Jenny that you
are entitled to a no-fault divorce if
your spouse is a Yeti or Sarah Palin all
right Andrew to drink minimum
don't touch the dancers next up areola
borealis oh what a great oh that's the
best stripper name ever Eric okay you
can walk away scot-free if you didn't
get a good look at them because it's
dark for six months out of the year yeah
[Applause]